[Music]
Josh one big poll by one vote
cody was the deciding vote how do you
like them apples his you know one-liner
before he voted kind of like showed that
he deliberately voted for Josh to win
they were like oil and water but the sad
thing is Paul wanted to work with Cody
in the beginning at some point and you
know the battle back Cody
but Cody has bribed this guy he sees the
world I think in black and white and he
was like no I called it I'm sticking to
my original opinion and I felt like it
was a very personal an emotional jury
that voted for Josh to win to be honest
but you know what Josh did work it's not
like he sat there he was not a floater
we didn't actually hear that term this
season although some people did float
yes though they don't know that they
floated puppetmaster
[Music]
Cody also taking home America's favorite
did that surprise you it did it did and
it didn't I don't know if we're allowed
to reveal by how much but it was no
question let's put it that way without
revealing numbers I was surprised
because in the beginning he was kind of
like the prom king and then suddenly
when he became on the outs and he wasn't
running the show and he wasn't you know
mr. popularity in the house he became
that's when America started rooting for
him we love an underdog it's weird to
look at you know the picture of cody has
an underdog you know he doesn't have any
an ounce of fat on him seeing it just in
Cody reunite tonight still think they're
gonna make it I do because of what
Jessica said Cody Bacchae loves this
woman I think everybody sees that I'm
rooting for them I think they have a
chance
love that all right Celebrity Big
Brother is coming what are you most
looking forward to about this kind of
different shortened game with famous
people you know we think we know famous
people because of the roles that they
play on the big screen or the small
screen what I'm looking forward to is
seeing what happens you know behind the
magic behind the hair makeup behind the
curtain so I'm looking forward to
getting to know even if it's a celebrity
that you know isn't really on my radar I
just want to see the human side of you
know have you thought about more names
you want to see in there the other day
oh I was thinking first I was thinking
Pam Anderson and then I thought or Tommy
Lee and then when I thought of Tommy Lee
I was like Axl Rose and I started going
down the whole like you know glam rock
metal dance and then did I see an ad
tonight that is just gonna pop back on
the talk soon Aisha is gonna be on the
live Thursday show Co guest co-hosting
so weird to call put the word guest yeah
but you know she is forever a sister on
the show and anytime her eight jobs
allow her to come in and pop in her old
seat that door is open and the seat is
open so yes how have the last two weeks
of as you called it dating been the
dating has been good well the first week
we knew they were um you know just a
drink it wasn't even a dinner because
these these guys you know the CBS
primetime you know hunks they have jobs
so we knew that was just so you know was
gonna be a relationship but you know the
first week of dating with Garcelle I
like ourselves you know I'm going on
more dates with Garcon
[Music]
you